the Joe Rogan experience dude
I look over the beard look at that and a
shots a turkey huntin turkey honey's fun
because it's like I swear to god there's
a feeling that you get when you kill an
animal that's not it's not a happy
feeling it's angry there's a there's a
remorse yep that is it's like engulfing
the happiness like there's happiness but
there's also like a remorse I get
serious they're sad no remorse when you
blast a turkey I'm here to tell you I
shot a turkey in the head I felt nothing
not only that I put it on Instagram
nobody gave a [ __ ] I was holding that
Turkey up by its feet I'm like shot a
turkey nobody cared I know nobody no
vegans care about Turkey's they should
die and if you around them you care
about him even less well everything
wants to kill a turkey to the point
where you have to cover your face
because otherwise they're like man they
run away we the size the one Steve god
that's a big turkey that's what I call a
big [ __ ] Tom yeah that's a big-ass
turkey man I love using I love using
hunting terminology around hunters so
they think I'm a more a more seasoned
hunter than their a cool animal Turkey's
a cool animal man really is really yeah
it's it's interesting it's a it's a bird
that kind of flies but doesn't ya be the
last bird I would choose to be they go
up in a tree yeah that's about it they
can just barely make it to a tree don't
worry about coyote Fox everything you
got to worry about everything everything
wants to eat you everything you know and
probably other birds oh hell yeah dude
this this my kids found out in my
neighborhood they found a [ __ ] my son
goes daddy there's a bird that's dead
and I go there and it was a dove with no
head and hands and it's chested Bini
mouth clearly by a bird of prey yeah or
an owl we have a big owl in the
neighborhood mmm oh yeah junk around
I had an owl that was killing Hawks in
my neighborhood yeah these Hawks were
all beheaded and this I just decided to
start [ __ ] up these hawks there is
one of the best videos that I've ever
seen online of animal interactions where
our swoops down it snatches a hawk out
of its nest you ever seen that yeah they
got a camera on this nest of hawks so
they kill Hawk Nicki or whatever the
[ __ ] they want give us
don't pollute listen that things of
ruthless [ __ ] kill cats - they kill
everything cats rabbits one of them I
was driving down the street to my house
and I was driving this owl was like
flying over the street holding a rabbit
and just decided I was getting too close
to him so he just let the rabbit go and
splat so I got out of the car to look at
the rabbit just disemboweled rabbit yes
tore this [ __ ] thing apart but this
video it was on my Instagram it's night
vision and you see these hawks just
hanging out in the nest like huh well I
guess we're look at this guess let's be
here for the night no look at the eyes
look at the eyes look at the eyes I
didn't know the other ones like no what
the [ __ ] happened
one more time watch look at the eyes
look at the eyes on the distance you see
the eyes here comes [ __ ] I love that
video
it says owl attacks hawk you can find
the video online on YouTube enjoy
[Applause]